[Music]
in two fancy news Oh mr. fancy submitted
by Gio's pinky toe oh I don't know
that's random I liked her pinky toe it
scrolled up oh thanks it's curled up
against the other one I do I think
that's uh it's like a genetic thing not
everyone's like that I notice of all
Asian people have that straight pinky
toe oh I never ends curled
there's curled in there Street I'm the
[ __ ] other my separated like
this
they have like a straight flat one which
goods weren't used to work in those
shoes and make them curls the only time
I ever notice is the second toe like
that yeah fat toe then cuz mine curves
down and I was always self-conscious of
it and then people start calling me a
good nitpick every [ __ ] thing it's
your [ __ ] PO it's nasty either way
and then I realized I'm crashing that
the thing tells me and I was like you
feel better
that's cute it's so hard being a girl
did ya they love overthinking Tokyo
students are being harassed in the
streets over there school-issued Armani
uniforms haha yeah I doesn't even seem
like Japanese behavior I know we get
harassed by because they have like $700
uniforms for a public school and so
these people are coming up to these kids
going is this our money is this Errani
how do they even know damn they're
pretty fashion-forward or even like pick
out Armani on the streets but watch
big-ass a or something nice
how can you tell tailored ass doe
actually looks clean oh they could tell
over there oh because um
so prior to China being the number one
consumer for luxury goods it was Japan
for like a decade so they were huge
consumers because if you I mean you've
been there and in shopping there right a
lot of things is boutique experience
yeah
so they'd like higher brands but they
want the low key stuff but they have an
eye for that so they don't need the LV
[ __ ] print all over they don't get
the loud stuff that's what Filipinos lat
they come over here they're like guess
everything no they get the low-key
boutique
I know China but I get like name-brand
JanSport backpack but that's I'm saying
it also doesn't seem like Japanese
behavior to be like yeah well maybe
their idea what's what what do they mean
by harassing you know they say are they
specifying like you guys should get
married well apparently I've gotten so
bad to the point that they've hired
security guards then the school is rich
crazy well it isn't that in the ginsa
district which is like geezer game the
district that's like the Japanese
Beverly Hills yeah really wealthy there
is a reason why though they don't go
loud so they all want quality goods
right but rich people dress down over
there and poor people dress up so
everyone wants to kind of be the same
that's so so interesting in this zone of
like that's why you don't see any poor
people because you don't know that
they're poor yeah they might be saving
up three months so they can get decent
collared shirt and they take it big take
really good care of that and you will
never know that they were broke so it's
so interesting like with rich people
like they're the richest [ __ ] is like
the most boring is blanchett and then
you what feels terrible when you buy
something hella dope and then nobody
notices yeah that's the worst feeling on
earth like you wet this Armani shirt
that you wanted you sit down and you
wait for everybody knows this go sup man
I really think it depends on what crowd
you're with too though cuz like I feel
like the only times I've been pressured
to wear like an expensive-looking shirt
is what I'm like with those richer
people were like all like us yeah yeah
so they can get pressure that also when
I have a low pressure know when I have
like a Rolex on or whatever and I'm
around guys that are like five ten
million worth I'm like yeah eternal hide
as watch yeah because don't that for
them like it there's different levels
right so like cute Joe yeah there's like
okay so like most people if you have a
BMW or Mercedes your your upper class
yeah right but then if you're dealing
with people who are eight figure people
that's their Toyota yeah that's
different but they don't care if I think
they probably have twenty luxury watches
that are $30,000 each their Butler's are
driving that their Butler's are driving
their BMW Jeff so then when you wear
that it's like oh you're cute you're
trying to floss
yeah I legit do the exact opposite if
I'm around people who I know are you
know monetarily better than me mmm
Tom megistus bummy as possible just
because I'm like [ __ ] you guys I went to
this super rich people are but they just
watch the night so I'm not talking about
like an event where I'm not talking
about like going over to someone's house
where they're rich because I don't
really care about that I'm talking about
like when you're going to an event where
there's like a red carpet and there's
like camera and everyone's in like some
nice ass thing I don't want to roll up
in my over 21 Forgan dress like that's
scared like I don't what that's what I
do it more I do it more than I went to
this [ __ ] crazy how many days did you
book by the way in my Hollywood I did
one so far
hahaha I got booked one and it's only
been two months good yeah but then it
got bad because then I only had one
expensive looking dress and so I wore it
to every see if you tried it I have to
do that it just it becomes crazy so at
this point and it's also because I think
you're also you have a funny channel you
could do whatever the [ __ ] you want so
as a comedian if I go to these like
events like there's this ABC event L&T
right I showed up in my [ __ ] Nike
track [ __ ] and my [ __ ] Japanese
fishermen vest went right in no you just
come from a workout it was like no my
dresser for the event that's what it was
I'm wearing shoes upscale oh man it
I can't I can't even like dress to their
level it's too expensive yeah I mean I
would be me you know I really like Rob
Dyrdek so but he always looks like he's
an outdated like skater guy 2002 skater
yeah but he doesn't give a [ __ ] he's
ballin but I'm super into watches so I
was like notice things like that and he
has a Skye dollar and this guy dollar
but all gold when it's 40 G's so he what
he's looking like he's wearing Walmart
clothes from head to toe and he had like
a 40,000 dollar watch I'm like that's my
style these are is just making headlines
the fact that this school have they've
got security guards cuz in Japan it's so
rare to see a guard at schools
especially in Japan because they're just
so nice there and everything yeah I went
so polite like you would never imagine
see but they're like getting harassed by
politeness like everyone's like well
where'd you get this I wanted it is it
other kids that are harassing them or is
it like adults and so just saying the
way they described in this article as a
pupils are encountering abusive
strangers Oh abusive because if it's if
it's kids like bullying in Japan and
Korea it's actually pretty [ __ ] big
bullying is really bad like legit like
almost like in Korea back a million my
mom would tell me like if it was the
prettiest girl they would like rip out
her hair they'll get razors the base is
yeah because everyone wants to it's
about like you know the crabs in the
bucket thing where one climbs up on the
other that's Japanese culture there's no
real like the group is supporting each
other when there's the when there's a
group goal but they don't like
individual like yeah you know that's why
they call you by the family name first
and everything you do is for the family
first and you don't want to stand out
like you don't you don't want to be too
ball in and if you are really ballin you
want to give a lot of that away there's
not that many millionaires and
billionaires because they give so much
because of the social pressure yeah it's
kind of like you don't want to be too
excessive you just want to contribute
everyone's constantly contributing and
everything is like this ecosystem of
middle is it's like forced communism
that's like the opposite of here it's
exactly the opposite everything is all
about the individual here what is your
uniqueness like speak honey
and now you stand out yeah yeah but over
there it's like how do you service your
people how do you service your family
how do you make the society better as a
group and then if you're standing out so
like let's say this school right
this becomes a new standard now it's
kind of like what about all these other
people who can't afford oh now that's
gonna be the standard you're just
raising the bar we all got to do this
now
it's like voluntary communism basically
yeah social pressure like when like a
nice way like where you were choosing to
give more kind of you know yeah we're
talking about these uniforms that they
are like voluntarily you don't have to
use these particular expensive Armani
uniforms but then they're saying like
all you to pressure well yeah all the
parents are gonna find them for the kids
anyways cuz they don't want to be the
ones left out right then yeah but I also
think there's a lot of pettiness and
jealousy no matter where you go in the
world yeah and it's just more apparent I
think in Japanese and Korean culture
because there's a social pressure to
blend yeah everybody has to blend and no
one should stand out yeah how hard it is
being a fat person in [ __ ] Korea like
it is it's [ __ ] devastating good like
that's all P Korean people talk about oh
you lost weight oh your face is smaller
did you lose weight did you gain weight
did you lose weight
every Filipinos do that too though every
[ __ ] conversation is about your
weight and like literally in my
household I had to tell my mom the stop
I was like you cannot come up to like me
or my brother or anybody else and keep
talking about their [ __ ] weight and
[ __ ] because it's maybe it might be okay
for you and your culture in Korea but
people don't take it like that here
so stop like they had to learn how to
not do that [ __ ] because but that's how
they complement each other though your
face looks really small like a [ __ ]
dumbass compliment is that but that's
like the dumbest [ __ ] thing what do
you like backhand compliment you in my
Filipino family their legs are like oh
you look so skinny you should eat
something and then you eat you're like
they're like oh you're getting fat you
should not have seconds I have a that's
like that every time she would see me to
be like I'm yeah you're a little dork
this time around well you got older and
you're about to die
minorities love talking [ __ ] yeah that's
like this [ __ ] I don't know why I love
visiting Japan but I don't think I can
be like that's living there working
there I could live there as a as an
adventurer tired of it that's different
from like working there and like being a
part of the society going to school
everything yeah I'd feel so trapped
don't they have a high suicide rate cuz
a lot of the pressure
well Korea just one yeah we just beat
their sorry asses like it keeps going
back and forth Japan and Korea who has
the high food term the over like the
work to death like overwork
I forgot the good job by then big job
yeah they do work to death in the
suicide Olympics calabria twins good
gold medal once again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]